this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
right here in front of me
i have apple's base m1 macbook air and
apple's bass
and one macbook pro so a thousand
dollars versus 1300 dollars and in this
video we're gonna find out if it's worth
spending the extra three hundred dollars
on the macbook pro because
there's not that much different as we're
gonna find out
and this one has the fan which the
macbook air is completely fanless
not only are we going to be testing the
performance seeing if the macbook air
thermal throttles and gets hot over
heats
using our thermal camera but we're also
going to test the differences that the
spec sheet doesn't show you like the
differences in
speaker quality the microphones the
displays and things like that let's
first get started with
the physical differences first off the
weight is actually very similar between
these two
you got 2.8 pounds on the macbook air
and
three pounds on the macbook pro so
there's not really that big of a
difference there
in terms of the thickness at the
thinnest points
of the macbook air it is thinner but
it's actually
thicker on the thickest point which is
actually pretty interesting
so if you think the macbook air is more
portable it's actually not they're
pretty much the same
as far as the ports they're identical on
both of these they both have two usb
4 ports which also support thunderbolt 3
as well now one thing that's interesting
is that the macbook air always used to
have better battery life than the pro
it used to have two extra hours but now
the pro gets up to three hours more
battery life
than the macbook air which is amazing
and the reason for that is because they
both
share the same n1 chip but the pro has a
physically
larger battery and on top of that the
macbook air only comes with a 30 watt
usbc
charger and the pro comes with a 61 watt
so it is gonna be charging
faster as well now before we get into
the display because there is a
difference there we're going to talk
about the
keyboards and the trackpad the keyboards
are basically identical they both use
the same
magic keys but you do get a little bit
more of a
comfortable typing feel on the air
because the air actually kind of slopes
downwards here so it's a little bit more
comfortable whereas with the pro
it doesn't it's completely flat so
sometimes it can
dig into your palm but in my experience
it's still not that bad the main
difference between these is that the pro
gets the touch bar and the macbook air
doesn't some people actually prefer the
ear
because of that reason now getting into
the track pads they both use the same
technology
force touch like this is the best
trackpad ever but the size is a little
bit different let me show you guys
as you guys can see the pro gets a
slightly
larger trackpad and i like that
i'm all about the larger track pads
especially on the larger 16 inch as well
now in the past we did have a difference
in the speakers between the air and the
pro so let's just test it one more time
and you guys let me know the differences
that you hear down below in the comments
[Music]
now i don't know about you but it seems
like the air actually has
louder speakers or at least the highs
are quite a bit louder compared to the
pro
but i did notice a little bit more bass
but in my opinion i would rather
go for the louder air because when
you're trying to watch a movie or
something with vocals
it's better to have more volume and it
still sounds really good in terms of the
webcam
quality apple didn't really change them
they're both the same 720p
webcams on both of these as they were
before but apple did add
the new image signal processor which
does make
the image look better now here we are on
the macbook pro and apple did say that
they added
studio quality microphones on the pro
this year so hopefully the microphone
should be sounding better
and different compared to the air you
guys let me know down below
moving on to display quality apple
actually upgraded the display on the
macbook air they added p3 wide color
gamut support
just like we had on the macbook pro as
you guys can see right here
you should be seeing the webkit logo on
both of them which
wasn't like that in the past this is
going to be really nice for people
trying to do
photo editing or color grading now the
only other difference
is in display brightness the macbook air
is limited to 400 nits
compared to 500 on the macbook pro as
you guys can see in that top camera but
overall in terms of the displays
in the past people had to go for the
macbook pro if they wanted to do things
like photo editing
but now you don't have to now you can
get the macbook air if you want to
with that let's go ahead and get into
performance as you can see we have
geekbench 5 open right here
but first i want to give a huge shout
out to squarespace for sponsoring this
video
if you've been thinking about making
your own website squarespace is
seriously the best way to go
we've built multiple websites with
literally no web making experience
you just choose a template customize
blocks of text and images
and easily move them around it's
incredibly simple affordable
and they've been running flawlessly for
over two years
bringing in new clients thanks to his
built-in seo tools
so whether you're making a website for a
small business or for
literally anything else go to
squarespace.com for a free trial
and use our custom link below when
you're ready to launch to save 10 on
your first purchase of a website or
domain
so here we are in geekbench 5 and as you
guys can see
we've got the macbook air with eight
gigs of memory and the macbook pro
also with eight gigs i am seeing a
difference here
on the m1 on the pro it's clocked
slightly higher 3.2 instead of 3.19
but let's go ahead and run this
benchmark all right we have our scores
and this is kind of funny they're
basically the same
within a margin of error even though it
has no fan the macbook air is getting
basically the same performance in
geekbench
5. of course that's not a stress test
we're about to do that in just a moment
but before we run cinebench r23 and bust
out the thermal camera i do want to test
the graphics
so let's run the metal test now while
this is running i do want to comment
that the base air does come with only a
7 core gpu instead of the full 8 core
gpu
on the macbook pro now what's really
surprising
is that amazon is actually discounting
the macbook pro right now so i'm going
to leave a link down in the description
below
so we have our scores right here as you
can see we're getting about 18
800 on the macbook air with a 7 core and
22 000 on the macbook pro which is
actually really impressive because
that's
reaching close to the 16 inch base
macbook pro score now what's surprising
about that score is that the pro has
14 more cores eight instead of seven
but it's giving us 17 more performance
which is
great now of course geekbench tests a
variety of different things
so let's run gfx bench metal and test
the gaming performance we've got our
scores back and this is actually very
interesting because we're getting
69.8 fps on the air and 77.5
on the pro that's actually only 11
faster so
it's not even that big of a difference
in gaming now if you guys are interested
in seeing how the real world gaming
performance is
we actually tested that out in our intel
macbook air versus
m1 macbook air video we got some really
crazy results and we also played some
ios games as well with controller
support now we are going to be doing a
full
gaming review and that is going to be
with this macbook pro so definitely
click subscribe
if you want to see that now let's go
ahead and answer the biggest question
that is on
all of our minds does the macbook air
thermal throttle and how much does a
throttle compare to the macbook pro
which has the fan before we begin i do
want to get an initial
thermal reading of both of these on the
macbook air side
it's looking like we're sitting at 28
degrees celsius
compared to 26 degrees celsius
the macbook pro is staying cooler at
idle
before i hit start i have to mention
that both of these are running extremely
cool
especially compared to the intel models
which you guys saw
in those videos that we did over the
past couple of days but let's go ahead
and get started
with the multi-core test it's been about
six minutes and the macbook pro is
definitely faster than the
air now what's really impressive is that
i still can't hear the fan at all it's
completely silent
just like the air but it is performing
better so far
the test is almost finished and i want
to get another thermal reading
looks like we're sitting at around 39 40
degrees celsius on the air
moving over to the pro we've got
37 degrees celsius
interesting oh i think it just hit 36 as
well yep
it did just hit 36. it's hovering
between 36 and 7. that's interesting so
we are getting a difference between
these two of around
two to three degrees celsius it's just
about finished and
only now after 10 minutes of full 100
cpu load i can now hear it slightly
if i put my head down near the macbook
pro i can hear that fan
and what's funny is that the pro just
finished and the fan already turned off
it's silent right now and we're still
waiting on the air to finish up
so what this basically means is that
unless you're pushing the processor
the macbook pro to its limits for almost
10 minutes
it's basically fanless because the fan
doesn't even turn on you can't even hear
it alright we've got our scores
and this is actually pretty impressive
because we're getting around 6 700
points on the macbook air
and 7 700 points on the macbook pro
that's a difference of
14 faster for the pro now in the past
there would be a much larger difference
when you're spending three hundred
dollars to get the pro
this is actually very impressive because
the air has no
fan at all and you're only getting 14
more performance
for 300 and that is basically the
biggest difference you're going to see
in
extreme cases because in our previous
comparison with the macbook air
we noticed that our first score was
around 7 400
but after about 8 minutes the thermal
throttling was accounted for and it was
able to keep itself cool
while at 100 cpu load so that's
basically it
14 more on the pro now on top of that in
the past the macbook airs would have
slower ssds compared to the pros
but as we're seeing here they're
basically the same
around 2200 write speed and
around 2700 read speed so
no difference there if you choose the
air moving on let's go ahead and test
out photo editing
we have lightroom classic open right
here and
it's actually not updated for apple
silicon it's still running
using rosetta 2 emulation now what i
have open here is
42 megapixel photos these are actually
pretty tough raw photos
it's tough to edit on some computers but
let's see how it performs between
the air and the pro let's zoom in and
out
this actually does stutter on some
computers
and as far as i can tell perfectly
smooth on both of them
now the next thing is switching between
photos so let's
right
now there is a little bit of lag
switching between photos but these are
massive files
with a lot of editing done to them in
between the two machines
i'm really not seeing much of a
difference so the macbook air
man it's performing well now let's go
ahead and export
50 of these tough raw photos into
jpeg i have a timer right here so
export start this export test is gonna
max
out the cpu and it's gonna use the
graphics as well so
this is gonna be interesting so it's
been around two minutes and 20 seconds
and now i can actually hear the fan on
the macbook pro that's interesting
because
cinebench didn't do that all right both
of them just finished
and it's interesting that the macbook
pro's fan turned off as soon as it was
done
here is the difference in the scores the
macbook pro finished the export in two
minutes in 58
seconds and the macbook air finished in
three minutes and
eight seconds so it's only a 10 second
difference
which is actually really impressive for
the air that's killer performance
without a fan
now just to put those scores into
perspective
our 2020 27 inch imac the 8 core model
for
2 300 with eight gigs of ram
took three minutes and 55 seconds
much longer than both of these macbooks
running under rosetta it's not even
optimized for apple silicon
now one thing we notice about lightroom
classic is that it's heavily dependent
on ram
like on that imac when we added more ram
the performance drastically improved so
it's interesting to see
if we're gonna get better performance on
these m1 macbooks
with the 16 gig version that's actually
gonna be
the next video that we're gonna be
working on because i know a lot of you
guys
are asking for that and trust me we're
gonna be working on that video next so
definitely subscribe down below and
enable the notifications so you guys
don't miss out on that
moving on a lot of you guys were asking
about logic pro
performance right here we have the new
logic
benchmark as you guys can find by just
searching it up on google
and in our previous comparisons between
the intel macbooks
and these new m1 macbooks we found out
that
around 95 tracks is the limit so let's
run this test and see if the macbook pro
can handle more than the macbook air all
right we've got 95 tracks
let's run it sounds a little bit weird
oh okay they both overloaded let me
disable
just one of those tracks and try 94.
oh okay they both overloaded at 94.
maybe 93. all right this is interesting
the macbook air
just overloaded but the pro is still
going
let's see if it's going to make it to
the very end and pass the test
it did not pass the test it did last a
little bit longer but it failed
let's go ahead and just test out 90
tracks and see if they handle it the
macbook pro is almost done with
90 tracks the air actually failed 90 so
i'm trying 89 right now let's see
there you go the macbook pro just passed
90 tracks
and the air just failed on 89.
that's interesting because before we
were able to get around 93 to 95 so
maybe there's a difference
on if there's some kind of background
task running which we close everything
but maybe there is something like that
so
the performance between these two for
logic is almost
identical we're running an insane amount
of tracks compared to the old
intel models which only ran about eight
tracks
so going from eight to above 85 tracks
is incredible and so far from what we're
seeing from all these tests
you're really not sacrificing much by
going with the macbook air because it's
performing
so well and so far the fan hasn't really
been that big of an advantage for the
pro now before i give you my final
verdict let's do one more test video
editing
in final cut pro this is gonna be
pushing the cpu
and the graphics to its limit so we
might actually see a difference
there let's go ahead and open it up this
right here is a five minute test it's
standard
4k h.264 footage which most people most
youtubers are going to be filming in and
editing and there are a couple of
effects like added film grain
and color corrections and some luts
so far from what i'm seeing
they're both playing this back perfectly
smooth
now what's really impressive about this
is that neither of those
intel macbooks could do this they would
both get
really hot and they would start
stuttering and you would not get
perfect playback like we're seeing right
here now let's go ahead and export
this 5-minute 4k project and see if the
pro
finishes faster alright it's almost done
and they're basically neck and neck 96
97
let's see it's just about to finish and
there you go they both hit a hundred
percent
at the same time this is kind of crazy
because the macbook air is performing so
so well
so both of these finish this export in
around three minutes and 5 seconds
which is mind-blowing because the
16-inch macbook pro
took over 3 minutes and 20 seconds and
what's even more interesting is that we
thought that the macbook air would be
throttling in video editing but
based on this test it's not now if
you're interested in seeing
more video editing results definitely
check out max's channel
max yurif i have a link down in the
description below because he tested out
davinci resolve final cut pro and
premiere pro and there's some
really interesting results there so
there you guys go that was
all of the testing and overall i am just
shocked blown away by the macbook air
because it is performing basically neck
and neck
with the macbook pro which we did not
expect
so basically if you're thinking about
getting the macbook air maybe for the
gold color
or the different design or the lower
price
a thousand dollars instead of 1300
then i'd say go for it so if you want to
buy one of these awesome new m1
macbooks we have links down in the
description below and if you're
interested in seeing
if there's a difference between 8 gigs
and 16 gigs of ram
we're gonna be making that video so
definitely click the circle about to
subscribe
and check out our other videos right
over there comparing these ones to the
intel
versions thank you guys for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]